we are witnessing some monstrous acts
being committed at the hands of the
israeli authorities
against civilian palestinians in
region and this is not something new
this is not something new that we are
witnessing we have witnessed this for
decades
since the advent of the so-called state
of israel in 1948 in may 1948
and that is simply because that state
has had an agenda
which has been uncovered now by
historians like ilan pape
and others like norman finkelstein who
have written extensively on these issues
whereby israeli authorities have been
exposed
for trying to ethnically cleanse
the areas of palestine from the arab
peoples
this is their agenda and why and how do
we know that
we know that from the records we know
that from
the days in which the very early state
of israel had plans
like plan elif and plan bet
and plan gimmel and not to forget the
most important
and severe of them all plan dalit
which explicitly mentions the intention
of the israeli government
or the israeli authorities to try and
dispose
of the land of trying to get rid of
quite frankly as many of the
palestinians as possible and they're
very
clear about those objectives only
someone who is
deluding themselves and who doesn't know
history
would pretend that that is not happening
in that area
as i've mentioned historians now look at
these
records like planned dalet and have
concluded
that this was the intention and is the
intention of the israeli authorities all
along
and if you look at what's been happening
from 1948
to this day you'll find that the
palestinian territories
have been shrinking in size in terms of
geographic location demography
and other things the question is what is
fueling
this conflict it's important that we
have the right diagnostic
to this so that we don't make rash
and hasty or generalized
or otherwise irresponsible judgments
as to why what is happening is happening
i want to submit to you today that what
is happening is happening not because of
religion
it's not because muslims hate jews or
jews hate muslims
or muslims cannot tolerate jews or jews
cannot tolerate muslims
or indeed because that within the
theological systems
of islam and or judaism there is a lack
of tolerance towards the other
and there are many things which can
prove this both contemporary
if you think about the last maybe 100
years
and medieval if you look at the
broad stroke historical trends that have
taken place
in many different countries in the last
thousand four hundred
and forty four years of islamic history
so let's go over some of those things
first because it's important
people are saying what should we do and
what is the solution
the first part of the solution is to be
educated about this topic
after one is educated about this topic
one can
have conversations based on knowledge
which can have a narrative
influencing effect both in the public
sphere and in private
circles that's the first thing and it's
always the case with the muslim
that at least from our perspective
everything should start with the pen
as allah the first thing that was
revealed
in the quran
who created who created who created the
human being from clubs
[Music]
and your lord is the most generous the
one who taught
with the pen with the pen so everything
must start
with knowledge and the pen even
islamic theology
know that it's everything starts
with knowledge so how do we
show how do we show
and prove that actually it's not a
religious tension
if you look at the history of muslims
and jews
starting with the conquest of jerusalem
in 638
by ahmad even someone
like michael sir michael gilbert who i
will link his article is a very short
brief and important read
read this article it's an incredibly
important article it's not written by a
muslim for propaganda purposes or
anything like this
by a british historian of the highest
eminence
the account that he gives and the
account that even someone like thomas
walker arnold
who is an orientalist gives in his the
preaching of islam a book an orientalist
book
some decades many decades ago and many
other people
give even bernard lewis who was one of
the most ardent and polemical people
against islam
and the islamic civilization all of
those people admit
that in fact that in fact there was a
there was an air of tolerance there was
an air of tolerance
and when um he came he allowed the jews
to settle back into jerusalem
and for those who know ancient history
will know that there was something
called the siege of jerusalem in 70 a.d
where the jews were literally kicked out
of their homes
at the hands of the romans you see how
subhanallah how history repeats itself
but now the perpetrators have become the
victims
and the victims have become the
perpetrators
the the perpetrators have become the
victims and the victims have become the
perpetrators
now it's not the roman empire kicking
out the jews from judea
now it's the opposite now it's the jews
kicking out the muslims from palestine
the original inhabitants but let that be
a side note for now
638 you had peaceful collaboration
you had a system where muslims
christians and jews all lived
side by side there was no
genocide no one has said this and in
fact this would be an a historical claim
that you cannot even make
you cannot make this claim there was no
for forced
religious uh conversion
even thomas walker arnold mentions this
in his book
there was giving to the jews
and to christians and to other
communities
a right to basically rule by what they
believe in
and this is extremely explicit in the
islamic texts
then you had then you had different
empires
and we can't go through a thousand four
hundred years of empires but
suffice it for me to say today that when
you had conviventia
convavencia in spain
in spain which basically means a
collaboration between jews christians
and muslims and
coexistence so much so that in 1492
when the expulsion of the muslims and
jews took place and the inquisition took
place
jewish people and gilbert sir michael
gilbert talks about this in his article
which you must read
jewish people ran to the ottoman empire
for safe haven
they ran to the muslims for say and what
did the ottomans do did they
kill them did they enslave them no they
did not
that is a historical they gave them a
space to worship
to believe and so on and before the
ottomans even
the spanish empire in the spanish
inhabited
muslim area or areas
you find that some of the greatest
jewish thinkers of all time
like musa bin mahyun maimonides existed
and he produced his best works under
muslims in fact
the enlightenment of the jews the golden
age of jewish
of the jury took place under muslim rule
it took place under muslim rule
so one cannot say
that in fact this is that the muslims
and jews had this
horrible relationship yes of course
there were times when muslims and jews
went to war
but that was i will i will put to you
that
was the historical exception and not the
rule
the rule was for hundreds of years
muslims had protected jewish people
so much so that someone like bernard
lewis
who gilbert mentions in his article
which i'll put down
someone like bernard lewis freely admits
and he is
as i mentioned a polemic against islam
and islamic civilization
that something to this effect that i'm
paraphrasing but the best time
in the uh the best time
in the in the muslim empire didn't
amount to the worst time in the
christian empire in other words
the the jews under the muslim
under muslim rule were not persecuted
in any way shape or form comparable to
that which happened in christian
rule with the spanish inquisition
and with the hitler with the pogroms
and so many other events that we can
cite
no such events equivalent to that
existed in the muslim world
at all according to bernard lewis and
this is mentioned by
sir michael gilbert so when did this
hostility start taking place
when did really the war start to
proliferate
and the hatred started to become
apparent to the degree
to which it is now sir michael gilbert
says that in fact this took place at the
advent of
zionism and this is a view widely
accepted among historians
if you look at the recent past if you
look at the recent past
you had of and obviously these things
require
lectures in their own but i will
passively talk about this and you can go
research in your time but you had the
balfour
declaration 1917 where
britain promised
the jewish people or the zionists at
that time
that they will facilitate for them a
homeland
in palestine and bear in mind britain
didn't have a mandate for palestine
in 1917 the war was still going on world
war one was still going on at that time
and so they had a mandate for they had a
mandate for
palestine in 1920 and from the years of
1920 to 1948
there was a struggle within where there
was a struggle within
palestine so much so
that what happened is in the 30s in
particular
in the 30s in particular you had
something called the arab revolt in 1936
which took place because of an
increasing
jewish immigration obviously you will
know if you know german history as well
if you study it gcses or whatever
that hitler became chancellor of the
exchequer in the early 30s 1933
and the nuremberg laws took place in
1934.
so in 1934 is when the nuremberg
starting to take place
that's where you find so many jews like
to come from germany but not just
germany
from poland and from russia and
different parts of the european world
and they were coming and overflowing
overflowing a country with very small
population which was at that time
palestine
and this culminated you could say in
what was referred to as the arab revolt
because
how can you bring all these people maybe
000 people according to huritz in his
book the struggle for palestine
he talks about and you can look at that
book because it's it's not even written
by
it's written by i think is mutual is a
jew himself
but it's a classic on this talks about
the fact that these people are coming in
in 30s early 30s
in swathes and overpopulating the
uh overpopulating palestine and then in
i'm quickly going through this you had
the white paper
and you can go and research what that is
it's a particular paper that took place
uh that was written by the british
mandate which
which caused very much agony and
commotion
and then after that you had in 1940
the establishment of it of
the military win with the blessings by
the way and this is according to herod's
of will of winston churchill that now
they decide to have the hagganah and the
urgon
and the hagana was a paramilitary group
and this is the beginnings of the jewish
state if you really want to
pin it down it was when they had defense
systems in place
the hagener the hagen up
in the 1940s early 1940s
and the irg which are a terrorist
organization
now they started to defend themselves
and what they mean by that really
especially in the case of the argument
is commit terrorist heinous acts which
were recognized as terrorists
terroristic by almost everybody the
americans the british and everyone
because in fact and i mentioned this
quite often
it culminated probably one of the most
severe terrorist attacks in 1946
where these people the of gun
went into the king david hotel and
killed 91
people innocents innocent people they
went into a hotel in jerusalem in east
jerusalem and killed people
and you see they were rewarded for their
terrorism
by the british and the u.n two years
later by getting a state
in their name in 1948
and what a precedent to set
what a precedent to set they were
rewarded for their terrorism
because the ruling powers and the man
the british mandate and so on they had
enough of this
and so the case was referred to the un
and 1948 lo and behold
you have the state of israel and then
you have
of course the wars you have a 1948 war
and then you have the 1966 war and the
1966 wars with
egypt and other neighboring states like
jordan and so on
where they lost decisively
because obviously america had a hand in
that war and
they were not prepared and they had arab
nationalism and they were not
really effective and then 1973
with another war which is held in
egyptian
history at least as one of the great
victories and i see why they think that
because at least they've regained sinai
they regained sinai in 1973
but we still have the issue as it is now
and then you have all these accords that
took place before
in between that time period and then you
had the struggle which continued
and you had the intifadas into father
one intifada
ii and then you had these operations
against
gaza cast lead and protective edge
two major operations which killed
claimed the lives of many different
people
in the early 2000s you also had the
removal of the movement
away of the jewish settlers from hazzard
under the reign of ariel sharon is very
interesting
because i actually watched some videos
of those individuals the jewish settlers
in gaza
they were leaving because they were
being told to leave by ariel sharon
and as they were leaving they were
destroying their homes and this exactly
mimics what happened to bernoull
which was a tribe of the jewish people
at the time of the prophet muhammad
that they destroyed their own homes
exactly the same thing they were exiled
and they destroyed their own homes
before they leave so they don't they
don't leave anything nice for
the muslims and now obviously you had
these other operations that took place
and we are where we are the question is
why is this all happening it's happening
because those
particular zionists have a racial
in exactly by the way zionism and nazism
are very similar
they're both nationalistic they're both
racially predicated
and they had exactly the same vision
really they wanted to see a country full
of people that homogeneous
that's their vision it's a racist vision
and now you have an apartheid state and
you have people who claim to be liberals
or even neoconservatives and other who
whoever they whoever they may be
who support the state of israel
what is our job and what do we do i'll
be honest with you
with razza and with the duffalga of the
west bank
the truth of the matter is it's it's
really a pessimistic case
henry kissinger once said something very
important
he said this to us sadet the egyptian
prime minister at the time of the
president at the time
he said to him you cannot win on the
negotiating table what you've lost in
the battlefield
and this is something true of life we
cannot expect as muslim people to have
to win on the negotiating table what
we've lost in the battlefield
that's the first principle the second
principle now the second point
is as it relates to charity
some people now mashallah pouring in
charity
and i'm not saying not saying that's not
a good thing but from my connections
that with the charity organizations
i'm not saying that has that putting
money into it is not a good idea
but it's limited because israel is not
going to let people go into yeah
so it's gonna it's gonna be stalled
people are gonna have the money the
charities are gonna have the money not
know what to do with it
or they might have the money and try and
transfer some of it but it's not gonna
be all effective
for me personally i personally believe
that the most
effective thing we can do in the west
is promote the narrative of racism
and terrorism and this is what israelis
it's a racist state and is a terroristic
state and when i say that
i don't mean that in jest in fact this
is historical reality
why is it a racist state for the reasons
aforementioned that they have
it's been revealed to us that they want
to ethnically cleanse
the place and make it people of the
homogenous
racial groupings why is it a terroristic
state
because those same people that bombed
the hotel that i talked to you about
people like muhammad
begin i don't know how to pronounce his
first name
he which wrote that he wrote a book
called the revolt
a revolting book who
talks about hate and how he he targets
civilians in his book is
you can get it from the library
this individual became the pr the
president of israel
this terrorist became the president of
israel from 1977
to 1981 can you imagine abu bakr
or one of those terrorists becoming
a president of a country and being
welcomed and having his hand
shaken by rulers across the world
someone who was part of an operation of
people who targeted civilians directly
he became the president and this is the
infrastructure of the current
lucid party in israel it has its origins
in a terroristic organization
in a racist terroristic organization and
the truth of the matter is they use
theological justification for this
the chosen people justification and the
quran challenges them on that by the way
says if you really believe that you are
the chosen people
if you are truthful yeah they believe
that this
the the ethnicity will give them
salvation
if that's the case then what are you
doing here we should be asking for death
the quran challenges this type of racism
and this ethnocentric approach to
theology
which is not in fact anything to do with
the
prophetic messages of moses or any of
the old testament prophets
especially those who are sent to ibn
islami the children of israel
no so having said all of this
the two things i recommend we must
expose
the terroristic and the racial nature
the anti-racial the racist
the racist character
of the israeli
government we must
this for me if there was an organization
or if there are organizations that are
specializing
just in exposing this narrative
that would be in this case for me and
this is not a fatwa or anything like
that
but for me if i was putting my money in
something i put it into that
and i think the people of palestine
would appreciate that the most because
that will be most likely to have an
effect
a policy effect to have to which will
eventually lead to some kind of relief
some kind of relief but having said that
i must admit i agree with kissinger
that this situation is not going to be
solved on the negotiating table
and i agree that
it's something which will probably
continue for a very very long time
and no amount of two-state solution
proposals
will be sufficient in this case or even
acceptable
morally to be honest with you from our
perspective and so for that reason
what i say to you as a muslim community
is this
if you care about palestine learn the
history
read the books and the articles and
promote the narratives
the narratives i've just said was